et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain éditorialistes alexis
poulain heureux de vous retrouver en
direct sur rt france alors la direction
se montre inflexible l'autre l'état
obtient cinq mois de négociations pour
éviter la fermeture que peut-on attendre
est ce que le dialogue social est déjà
rompu
oui le dialogue social est largement ont
pu on al'âge simplement un théâtre
triste où les politiques
systématiquement sont aux portes de
l'usiné
quand elles ferment ils sont là quand
elle ouvre quand il donne de l'argent à
des multinationales qui n'ont pas besoin
et ils sont là quand elle ferme pour
faire croire qu'ils ont encore un
pouvoir
ça fait longtemps que c'est le même
cirque ce tragique pour les salariés
pour les employés qui eux veulent sauver
leurs emplois
on a eu les continental on a eu
bridgestone ou new world poule vous en
parliez on a eu d'autres fabricants de
pneus tout ça n'arrête pas tout
simplement parce que c'est la
mondialisation que l'emploi quand il
dépend d'une entreprise internationale
il est extrêmement volatile le problème
c'est que ce sont des entreprises qui
ont avec elle des cabinets de conseil
comme accenture et d'autres qui leur
disent ou investir parce qu'il ya des
aides de l'état dont qu'elle vienne en
disant que bien sûr elles sont là pour
le long terme qu'elles vont s'investir
dans la région qu'elles vont aider à
créer un bassin d'emploi et puis quand
la conjoncture va changer donc en
l'occurrence crise du corps d'un virus
baisse de la croissance baisse de
l'achat de voitures et bien elles disent
qu'elles ne peuvent pas soutenir les
activités elles ne rendent pas l'argent
bien entendu en revanche elle mettre
tout le monde dehors
et puis elles continuent leurs activités
sur le territoire européen ou ailleurs
en pologne notamment
ça a été le cas pour pour vous pour les
continental donc rien ne change ce qui
est sinistre c'est de voir les
politiques toujours là à la manoeuvre
faire croire qu'ils ont un quelconque
pouvoir ils n'ont aucun parce que ça
s'appelle la mondialisation parce que
depuis des années des dizaines d'années
les idéologies dominantes fait que la
mondialisation doit être heureuse et
qu'elle est censée apporter croissance
et emploi c'est vrai une partie du temps
on est rentrés maintenant dans l'autre
côté de la mondialisation où les grandes
entreprises préfèrent aller là où
l'emploi est moins cher sachant que de
toute façon des des cargos entiers de
pneus peuvent venir en europe
ça ne posera aucun problème donc vous
avez deux crises écologiques économiques
qui sont tout à fait liés parce que les
entreprises
si de ne plus produire sur des
territoires et des politiques qui font
semblant de ne pouvoir rien faire qui
fondent qui ne font rien d'ailleurs
puisque dès que vous leur demandez de
faire des lois protectionnistes
il n'en faut aucune parce que nos grands
champions du cac 40 prenant michelin qui
fabrique des pneus eh bien ce sont aussi
des entreprises internationales
michelin ne produit plus de pneus sur le
territoire français ils ont des centres
de recherche et développement
parce que tout simplement ils font comme
les grosses entreprises mondiales
ils choisissent là où l'emploi est le
moins cher en france c'est pas le cas on
a décidé que l'emploi avait un prix
qu'il fallait payer les gens
correctement et même correctement
parfois c'est pas assez
et voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
ce n'est que la même scène d'une longue
litanie qu'on aimerait voir s'arrêter
mais malheureusement je vois pas demain
comment ces responsables d'hier qui sont
aujourd'hui au pouvoir pourrait changer
quoi que ce soit c'est à dire que quand
agnès pannier une hache et se déplace
sur place aujourd'hui quand elle dit que
le gouvernement va mener une contre
expertise pour vous il n'y a pas de
solution derrière n'y a pas
d'alternative finalement c'est plié non
vous avez une alternative réelle c'est
la coopérative c'est ce qu'ont fait les
lip à l'époque un qui reprennent l'usiné
qui les ouvriers qui relancent lusine
parce qu'ils connaissent leur métier
parce qu'il sauve les machines et parce
qu'ils vont créer des compétences se
former sur le tas et arriver à quelque
chose
laquelle est la réponse de la ministre
c'est cocasse c'est malheureusement
triste mais ça fait sourire c'est de
payer un cabinet de conseil accenture
avec nos impôts
formidable que va faire le cabinet de
conseil bain il va dire oui à peut-être
d'autres solutions possibles
mais en quoi cela va sauver les emplois
c'est gagner du temps tout simplement
peut-être gagner même deux ans pour
qu'en 2022 emmanuel macron ne soit pas
pris pour responsable de la fermeture de
l'usiné
mais sur le long terme sur le pérenne le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui la chine a
le droit d'envoyer des pneus très peu
cher sur le marché européen et que tous
les fournisseurs et bien vont se fournir
là où c'est le moins cher est que nous
ne mettons pas de barrière l'europe ne
qui protège n'existe pas elle ne protège
pas aux frontières
les lions nous ne faisons rien pour nous
protéger parce que nous avons peur en
fait de la réponse de ses grands marchés
qui pourraient fermer l'entrée des
produits européens sur leur marché sur
les états unis ou la chine
donc l'europe est pieds et poings liés
par rapport à cette mondialisation et
nos emplois industriels
eh bien ils migrent ils migrent vers les
pays où la main d'oeuvre est la moins
chère et pour ça
malheureusement les politiques ne
peuvent rien sauf s'il décide
effectivement d'avoir une politique
protectionniste mais ils en sont loin
et aujourd'hui ce que je vois comme
beaucoup c'est simplement des
gesticulations électoralistes
entre 2008 et 2016 l'usiné tu es était
sous perfusion puisque cinq cent mille
euros ont été alloués à l' usine par le
conseil régional des hauts de france
est ce que le gouvernement finalement
s'est emparé du sujet trop tard alors
que 8 163 salariés on le rappelle sont
concernés oui trop tard parce que c'est
une politique de long terme c'est à dire
que ces décennies de croyances
idéologiques dans la mondialisation où
nous avons ouvert grands toutes les
portes du marché français du marché
européen par par intérêt parce que comme
je le disais nos entreprises ont aussi
besoin des marchés internationaux
ça ne se change pas en quelques mois et
ça ne va pas changer en quelques mois et
que tout cet ancien sur le plan de
relance sur la relocalisation
elle n'a aucun sens sans l'autre pendant
de cette relocalisation c'est à dire le
protectionnisme faire qu'aujourd'hui des
produits produits à l'étranger coûte
plus cher sur nos marchés nationaux
alors là à ce moment là les entreprises
internationales seront obligés d'avoir
des productions locales pour les vendre
sur le marché local mais nous en sommes
loin tout simplement parce que c'est du
donnant donnant et parce que tous les
leaders que nous avons aujourd'hui et
certains commentateurs qui critiquent la
baisse de croissance en disant que si
finalement les usines ferment c'est
parce qu'il ya trop de gens en vélo et
pas assez de gens qui achètent des
voitures c'est stupide comme pensée
c'est pas du tout ça le problème le
problème c'est que nous ne protégeons
pas nos emplois que nous ne protégeons
pas la production neuve ne faisons plus
de machine à laver sur notre territoire
je rappelle que la suisse a encore deux
usines de machine à laver
c'est un manque de volonté politique est
aujourd'hui et bien c'est simplement
être là parce que les caméras sont là
parce que l'opinion publique s'en empare
mais que va-t-il se passer parce que là
on parle du plan social de bridgestone
mais combien de plans sociaux vont
arriver dans les mois qui viennent avec
la crise économique que nous vivons
j'attends de voir ce que feront les
politiques à ce moment là merci beaucoup
alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à nos
questions directes sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes